good morning John in my last video I
complained and my first rant of all my
rants was ranting about ranting and why
people enjoy ranting and listening to
rants so much when the world is actually
full of pretty cool stuff so in this
video to counteract that I'm going to be
sharing 15 of my very favorite feelings
in the world effort it's not gonna be
super funny it's not gonna fire your
dopamine receptors in the same way that
getting all jazzed up and angry will and
it might not even be like so relatable
instead of those things I'm just going
for honest so my favorite feeling's
seeing two people that you really like
get married to each other and everybody
in their lives who love them have come
together to just be uh neurotically
sappy about how adorable their faces are
for a day hanging out with an old friend
for the first time in years and you've
forgotten a lot of things about them and
you're hanging out and you they're just
great and you're like I like you so much
we get along really well that's probably
why we used to hang out like every day
figuring out something super complicated
like for example this thing just sits
there on the floor now that's not one of
my favorite feelings having just junk
lying around the complicated thing can
be like a real problem that I face in my
life or some contrived thing from a book
or a video game that moment of figuring
it out is so great I guess somewhat
relatedly just getting better at stuff
like that moment when you realize that
you can now do something very easily
that a year ago would have been
unthinkable difficult having the power
to feel comfortable being me and having
society recognize you for your strengths
it's pretty rare and pretty rad and I
have that right now and I never want to
take it for granted and when and if I
don't have it anymore which is certainly
possible I do not want to be bitter
about having someone you respect tell
you that they respect you mmm so good
when you're reading a book and they're
like 35 different weird plot threads
that seem to have nothing to do with
each other until one thing is removed or
added to the equation and suddenly they
all form together this magnificent
tapestry of everything and it all fits
together and you're like what just
happen love that I love that Allah doing
something scary and having it go really
well taking a hot shower in the dead of
winter
telling the first iris of the year not
like of an eyeball an iris is a plant if
you don't have those don't sniff each
other's eyeballs unless it's consensual
maybe the best feeling of all feelings
that I've
her head is opening up and letting
somebody that you love see all your
broken bit and then Dave like I don't
mind those are pretty cool you're mine
too and you're like yeah no I like those
those are cool that's fine we should
hold and hug knowing that yes this
person that you love loves you back and
you can trust that and you can know it
forever yeah that's good than that but
still very good is when the cat is like
don't you stop moving I need to cuddle
you another amazing feeling learning
things that helped me understand the
world better also helping people learn
things that help them understand the
world better now finish this list off
with a feeling that I thought would feel
really good but now that I've
experienced it a few times clearly does
not watching bad people who have done
bad things to me or to other people and
I've seen it happen watching those
people fail or self-destruct or how bad
things happen to them it never feels
good watching bad people is sad when
they're successful and when they're
failing it doesn't matter what's happen
I'm going to be honest I found this
video surprisingly hard to make even in
a little corner of the internet that we
inhabit that is a very open and honest
and authentic place it was difficult to
just share things that I like I don't
know why it's self-consciousness or if
it's like I'm afraid that I'm bragging
that I like enjoy things in my life
which is why would you feel that way I
don't know apparently it's more fun to
complain and to appreciate but probably
not better for a person or the world in
the long term so I know some of the
things above were like probably things
that everybody agrees on and some were
very specific to me but I'd like to know
in the comments if you just want to open
up and tell everybody else some of your
favorite feelings that would be great
also if you want to open up about some
of your hang-ups to consenting strangers
probably down there as well John I'll
see you on Tuesday